[Music]
hello and welcome to women with balls
where i katy paul's talk today's
trailblazers
my guest today is a radical feminist
journalist and activist
growing up in darlington she left school
in home at 15 and moved to leeds in
search of in her own words scary
sounding feminists
as the years went on her voice became
stronger fighting against male violence
prostitution and pornography
in the 90s she covered a justice woman a
law reform group which helps women who
have been prosecuted for killing violent
male partners
more recently she has taken center stage
in the gender critical debate amongst
other radical feminists such as jk
rowling and suzanne moore as a result
she has faced no platforming at several
universities in the uk
my guest has offered a number of books
including straight expectations the
pimping of prostitution and feminism for
women the real route to liberation she
says if men aren't threatened in any way
by your feminism then we're doing
something wrong my guest today is judy
bindle
julie thank you for joining us today and
for coming into the office which we
always love for a guest um on this
podcast we always tend to begin by
asking would you describe yours as a
happy childhood i mentioned the
beginning that you left home quite young
my childhood was very happy but it
wasn't without difficulties and that was
because
we were raised in the northeast of
england
which has usually almost always been
ignored
by politicians and by those in the rest
of the country in the uk
and
my father worked extremely hard he was a
steel worker he worked shifts he worked
extra shifts
um for money for
the three children
and
it was tough grueling work my mum worked
all the way throughout our childhoods
and we
were quite hard up
but
very well looked after always had
holidays
and
our parents were extremely loving my two
brothers one older one younger we fought
like cat and dog of course as you're
supposed to
and life was sometimes hard
um so why did you decide to leave home
so young
well i
was bullied in school
i
was identified as a lesbian before i'd
really formulated
what that meant i had a crush on my best
friend and i suppose my puppy dog eyes
and the fact that i wasn't interested in
the boys at my school although if you'd
met the boys at my school you wouldn't
have been interested in them i think it
was the best kind of lesson um and
teaching
of the lesbian faith possible going to
my school
and so i was identified as a leisure as
they called me
and i suppose there were two choices
for the boys in my school you were
either a slag
or a lesser
and i came to realize that actually
being a lesbian was way preferable than
snogging them and more around the back
of the bike sheds
so
that led to
me being seen as very different
and
the girls were also
scared
because they've been told that we were
all sexual predators
and i was quite naughty in class because
i was being bullied
and eventually i just thought i'm not
learning anything here i loved english i
loved literature i loved the written and
spoken word but i was failing at every
other lesson
and my school was terrible
so i just for the last year of my
official schooling i didn't go in
and
by the time i got to 16 the option was a
job in a factory
which would then lead into
marriage to
a boy on the same
council estate
a few kids that you couldn't really
afford to raise
and a life of drudgery
and i decided
there's more to life than this
and actually my mum
who
was not in any way active in politics or
feminism
was very forward thinking because her
mom was
and she recognized
that girls are left out that she
probably would have lived her life
differently had she had the
opportunities
that she didn't have as a working-class
woman in the northeast with no
education
and so she didn't discourage me
from flying the nest and in fact she
gently encouraged me despite the fact
that it was a loss for her to lose her
daughter
to lose that
immediate relationship
she knew that i hated shopping so that
probably helped her not worry about me
leaving her i was never going to be
doing that with her
um you mentioned uh the north east being
an area which traditionally you know
governments and other groups um have
neglected were you quite politically
aware growing up yet um then
given obviously what your mum was saying
to you too
well politically aware probably no my
family were labor voters our labor
voters
and
my dad was a union activist
and so he would talk a lot about the
tories
and he'd talk a lot about
he wouldn't frame it like this but it
was obviously about class inequality
about the division between the north and
the south
and my mom
would obviously do the same we saw class
inequality everywhere we went
just over the back from where we lived
on our housing estate
there was
a place called mountain
which is where the posh people lived and
there was literally a beck dividing it
and we used to occasionally cross the
back
to go to the pub when we weren't allowed
to so age 15 to meet with the posh boys
and actually um
one of the posh boys that i met during
that time was the comedian now known as
vic grieves
and
my god they were
miles apart i mean that was the longest
mile in the northeast of england from my
estate to where the posh once lived
now you go and say your aunts i believe
uh before you go to leeds um so
what while you're at your answer that
makes you then decide to actually go to
leeds where i mentioned the introduction
you know seeking out scary sounding
feminists which i say is your words
rather than me saying feminists are
scary
well i i left home at 16 and went to
live with my aunt in harrogate which is
a blue rinse town as we call it so it
was a tory town it was very different
from darlington but my aunt lived on a
housing estate
betty's and yeah i mean betty's tea
shops there which is horrific um
as twee as you can imagine and just the
kind of place that
really you would never ever want to go
to
and weirdly in harriga there was a gay
bar
and i say weirdly because it just isn't
the kind of term where you would expect
that so i went to the gay bar
um
met a couple of young gay lads who i
befriended
and
i also went to this campaign meeting
and i met
the out lesbian
there was one
i think she was from york
and through her i made friends
with young women i had no desire i
wasn't seeking a relationship i wanted
to meet friends
and in those days feminism and
lesbianism were pretty indivisible
many of the feminists were lesbians
and the lesbians embraced feminism
because they saw that the treatment that
they were receiving
by bigots was to do with sexism how dare
women not um want to be in a
relationship with men how dare they
reject us sexually so it was very very
enmeshed
and from there
i met my girlfriend and we moved
together to leeds which was
then
really one of the hot spots
of the scariest feminism that you have
ever seen
it was full throttle feminism
there were women there who were
picketing sex shops sex cinemas
raging about the
west yorkshire police
inadequacy to say the least in dealing
with domestic violence that often ended
up with women being
murdered
because they hadn't intervened but also
significantly dealing with
the fallout of
peter sutcliffe who was known as the
yorkshire ripper killing women with
impunity
and the police and the media together
completely messing up due to we argued
in our feminist group
misogyny
and the way that women are seen as
either
worthy victims or worthless victims and
so it was within that context in 1979 at
the very end
that i became
involved in active feminism and i was
my age was i i was just
17 i was 17 and i was very young and i
was about 15 years
younger than everyone else
and so they mentored me and they
talked to me about the history of
women's liberation
they'd all been on the left i hadn't
been involved in any other politics
they told me which books to read which i
would kind of look at the first page and
then look at the
end page and pretend i'd read the whole
lot
and the back of the book is usually
quite good
i learned very quickly how to do that i
still do that when i review books that's
a joke
commissioning ed
that was a joke
um
i wondered on on that um
[Music]
for listeners what what does active
feminism look like because lots of
people these days you know say this is
what a feminist looks like so during
that and obviously there's different
waves of feminism
and some people they're very hyper aware
and other people look at it and just
not really sure what differentiates it
so i wanted you to talk us through what
is active feminism in that period well
that's a really good question and i
think crucial
to
how we're operating today
with feminism much of it being online
and i have no issue whatsoever with
women
connecting and doing some activism
online i think it's it's a real leveler
and it means that women
who live far apart from
feminist hot spots
can be involved but i'm talking about
the keyboard warriors
those that sit and think that sending a
tweet means that you have just done
something feminist and it's usually
condemning a feminist actually in
today's orwellian world
active feminism to me means that you
don't just read about it
talk about it
do it in your nine-to-five job for which
you are paid but that you also
get onto the streets under visible
and go and demonstrate outside a court
where
yet another man is about to be found not
guilty of murdering a woman because he
uses the rough sex defense
or lobby your mps because they have
supported a law that will
result in material harm to women and
girls
that you meet with women and talk about
the reality of our lives under that very
old-fashioned word patriarchy still
relevant today unfortunately i mean i
will stop saying patriarchy when we're
post-patriarchy but for now it's quite
helpful and so it has to mean that you
do things that you contribute to a
movement in whatever way is possible for
you
that ends in a
or moves towards material change and it
can't just be thinking about it
condemning
other forms of politics
or
i suppose virtue signaling about what
you think is acceptable
or an acceptable way to do to do it
do you think and obviously there's lots
of different ways we can define feminist
issues but do you think it is more
acceptable to be a feminist in the way
that you've been
uh you know has it become more
acceptable back when you were in leeds
and it was scary sounding feminists
or not i mean is the reaction you're
receiving um better
i suppose maybe right now as maybe in
blocks of time we should take it rather
than just immediately back then and
right now
well
something that's very apt at the moment
when we look back at the suffragettes
and we look back at those women
who were very active out there
campaigners
and when we look at today is i suppose a
phrase is very apt is different century
same [ __ ]
so obviously things have moved on hugely
thanks to feminist activists those that
focus on male violence and how to end it
and how to
support women and not to blame women and
girls when they're at the receiving end
of male violence we have made huge
strides you know it's embedded in law in
culture
in politics in every institution of this
land it doesn't mean that we don't go
one step forward two steps back because
at the moment i think that we're living
through
a time of the most unbridled misogyny i
have seen in over four decades of
feminism
and i'll explain why
um you asked me how
my feminism was received back in the
very late 70s and throughout the 80s in
leeds and how it is today well
back in the 1980s there were unbridled
sexists
and there were men's rights activists
saying feminists have gone too far you
[ __ ] are responsible for divorce for
every social ill you need to get back in
your place
then in the 1990s there were there was
the new new kind of
wave
of sexist which is men's rights
activists that
were received quite well
by governmental departments
um
by the legal system
by representatives
with influence they would say look
you know we don't hate feminism we think
women deserve their rights but men's
rights are being eroded and we now can't
see our children when we get divorced
the family courts are mean to us
we're not asked about how we suffer
domestic abuse i mean she nagged me
relentlessly and where's the refugees
for us and then they talk about women
abusing children way more than men and
they skewed the figures and they skewed
the reality
of women's lives
and our oppression to make it as though
they were the victims we saw it with
fathers for justice families need
fathers they were dressing superhero
outfits and they would you know climb up
tall buildings and shout about how women
are divorcing them for no good reason
and taking their children away and then
we reach
where we are now
which is
a state where
men on the left
who
claim to be progressive
who've never liked feminism
because we challenge them about their
use of pornography
about them joking about prostitution and
brothels and how they fail to understand
how when they sit on all male panels to
talk about progressive issues that that
is wrong and unjust that they're pushing
women's voices out so men on the left
largely not all but mainly
have always hated feminists like me
the feminists like me that challenge
them directly
not the fun feminists not the fun
feminists that kind of
operate a kind of feminism light that
men are never ever threatened or
challenged by but feminists like me they
hate us
so now they can scream turf
and bigot and nazi and fascist
because we are
critical of extreme transgender ideology
because we're critical
of the phrase sex work and the
normalization of systems of prostitution
that abuse millions of women the women
at the bottom of the pile
all over the world
they call us swerf sex worker
exclusionary radical feminist and turf
which is
trans exclusionary radical feminist
and actually i'm not going to say the
word but there's a four-letter word that
they'd rather be calling us women and
turf has substituted that now i want to
talk more about sex work and also issues
as you're saying some of the criticism
when it comes to trans issues but just
before we do you mentioned violence
against women and in 1990 you
established justice for women with your
partner um
harriet and
also hilary mccollum
right um
and i wonder could you just talk uh
listeners through
audrey why you did that and perhaps some
of the most memorable cases so as to
show because clearly it played quite an
important role in some things you're
saying which is the fact things are not
as bad as some of these issues
i moved to london in 1987 from leeds and
at that time i was very focused along
with a group of a disparate kind of
group of feminist campaigners against
male violence
on issues such as sexual assault and
domestic violence and homicide and there
were men up in court we sometimes would
observe the trials from the public
gallery
and these men were up in court um for
killing their wives because she nagged
him or because she was allegedly
unfaithful
and we came to
name that the nagging and shagging
defense because it was literally a get
out of jail free card at that time
judges would feel sympathy towards these
men and often they'd get a non-custodial
sentence for manslaughter
at the same time there were women who
had been convicted
of murder for killing a man who was very
abusive and violent and she'd killed him
as a last resort because nobody had
stepped in between him and the violence
and her
and there was one notorious case that we
heard of sarah thornton who had killed
her husband um
after he threatened to kill her child
and had targeted her for abuse
but she was convicted of murder
and so we continued to
publish newsletters feminist newsletters
speak at meetings this was pre-internet
of course
about these cases and at the same time
we were also campaigning along with
other groups of women to criminalize
rape in marriage
because it was completely legal to rape
your wife
and this was outrageous
we knew that every woman who experienced
domestic violence would also experience
sexual assault because a man that beats
his wife on a regular basis is also
going to have sex with her whenever he
wants and she's going to be too scared
to say no and many women didn't even
know that raping marriage
was
in any way rape or that it was legal or
illegal they had no idea it was part of
the domestic abuse pattern
that law was changed in 1992 thanks to
feminist efforts
and
from then we
we realized that we needed to
form an organization that would bring us
together and that would focus on
several issues but in particular the
injustice of women as defendants in
court who had tried to respond to male
violence
and ended up themselves being victimized
not just from that violence but by the
criminal justice system we were aware of
cases such as kirinjit alawalia
who
a group called south all black sisters
still going really strong had campaigned
for she
um was an asian woman who had killed her
husband after the worst worst 10 years
of abuse
he would rape her in front of her
children
torture her there was no escape for her
she eventually killed him again like
sarah thornton was convicted of murder
and sent to prison for life
and we joined that campaign and
eventually she was freed
as was sarah thornton the courts
understood thanks to our campaigning
efforts and public awareness raising
that these women were victims and should
never have been
clusters murderers and then there was
emma humphreys
who contacted justice for women in the
early 1990s who had killed her pimp when
she was just 16 years old she'd had a
lifetime of abuse by then
and he put her out on the streets raped
her
and uh
and she killed him and was in prison for
seven years by the time she contacted us
in 1992
and she was also eventually
freed on appeal and the laws were
changed to recognize what happened to
these women and also to draw the
contrast between men like joseph mcgrail
who had killed his wife because she was
nagging he'd kicked her to death and the
judge said this woman would have tried
the patience of a saint before giving
him a non-custodial sentence so that's
why we started justice for women
and you mentioned the cases sarah
thornton and the prostitution has been a
large part of your work
um
but i i i wondered in the sense that you
recently wrote about your experience at
york university um which is an
experience you don't want to repeat um
but for listeners uh pretty hostile
response to you speaking there and part
of that is to do with the trans debate
but it was also i think you uh you know
some people saying oh there are sex
workers at york university you choose to
do that and and so and
i wondered is it
is there an intergenerational do you
think difference in how people view sex
work these days because you have sites
like only fans and
i've definitely found from conversations
i have with you know people in the early
20s and then i'm a group who's probably
i'll still say early early 30s um that
that is
probably my my kind of peers will see it
as a much more dangerous website whereas
the younger woman i speak to will think
is actually much more liberating
there are hundreds of ways to be a
feminist but most of them are wrong
and and this is absolutely the case um
i'm not actually even joking
i don't mean that you have to sign up to
a set of prescribed
beliefs or ideals but there is a basis
to feminism which is it's against the
subjugation of women and against men's
rights to abuse and dominate women and
it's for the liberation of all women
and some of these women who are calling
themselves feminists are anti-feminist
so those that are arguing
that sex work is
regular work that it's labor it's a job
like any other um it's the oldest
profession what they're doing is that
they are
ignoring the plight of the most
disenfranchised women on the planet
there's a cohort of highly privileged
women and men
that identify themselves as sex workers
who are atypical of the sex trade
and i know i've traveled the world
looking i've been in
legal brothels illegal brothels and
everywhere in between i've talked to
pretty much everyone involved and
hundreds of survivors of the sex trade
including those women that are still in
the sex trade
and what you find is male entitlement
that is off the scale
a view of women that is deeply
disturbing and often
grossly misogynistic
and so some of these tourists as i call
them the highly privileged phd
kind of
white
highly articulate highly educated women
and men
that speak for the sex trade as sex
workers
um dip in and out of it doing bits of
bdsm bits of escorting here and there
and of course the woman who
has a phd
is highly privileged and educated
has a second home in the cotswold sends
her kids to private school has never
been raped by a punter has no alcohol
and drug dependency because of the
trauma
has been treated
beautifully by her sweet-smelling
handsome richard gear clients of course
she exists
never met her she will be there
somewhere so does the black british man
in his forties who's never ever
witnessed or heard of any racism
i'm sure he also exists
but they're atypical and when i get
accused of of being homophobic i mean
talk about a tongue-twisting ridiculous
term to use against a feminist
who
campaigns to end abuse in the sex trade
what they're failing to see is that this
is this is actually critical of the men
and the normalization
of sex buying
of pimping this is nothing to do
with the right of a woman to do what she
wishes with her body i'm no threat to
women who decide that they want to sell
sex to earn a living
this is not the woman who is doing wrong
in any way
it's the pimps the brothel owners the
punters those that normalize
the most horrendous
form of unbridled cruel sadistic
capitalism
that we have
seen
and how men on the left or women on the
left
can defend such a gross industry
that abuses
women of color
care leavers sexually abused girls
poor girls and women all over the world
i failed to see
and you mentioned richard gere i
recently actually had pretty women come
up in my um thanks
what do you do you think that films is
dangerous or or people can just work out
what they want from it
well pretty woman now
is kind of
i look back on it with nostalgia in a
way that i do the ira now that we've got
isis
you know it's
yeah at the time it was pretty dangerous
i remember
going into a school um 16 year old girls
16 17 year old girls in russia
in quite a poor area
talking about feminism and half of the
class wanted to be as they put it
prostitutes
when they left
school
they saw that they had no opportunities
they'd been told it was great i mean if
you look at julia roberts
and and her
friends on the streets in that film
how healthy
does she look i mean this is not real
life
richard gere is not real life none of it
is and ask yourself this about pretty
woman it was a hugely successful film
wasn't it
it grossed
millions and millions and millions it
went all over the world
what usually happens with films that are
that successful
sequel
pretty woman too
where's pushy woman too
there can't be pretty woman too
because by the time we get to pretty
woman too
he's called her a [ __ ] and kicked her
out he's taking her kids off her
and she's on drugs
and he's got some other woman
so
none of it's real life
um now you mentioned uh earlier on about
obviously the term turf and i'm using
inverted commas um and obviously we're
talking about york university a little
bit too
i wondered i mean
if you're feeling as though you're
facing as as a group greater
as scrutiny might even as it's probably
the wrong word anyway uh greater
opposition regrets um
there was recently uh a lunch that you
wrote about for unheard
and i just wanted um how
you mentioned how more people are
actually as a result of some of the
hostility towards the movement um you're
actually seeing more young women come
out and then i think there's also um the
launch of jk rowling and others is that
how is that support group stronger than
ever when you're faced with you know
people
arguing that you know you're an
extremist
the issue is not about trans rights we
all support trans rights trans people
have rights enshrined in law
um that's unquestionable i'm a lesbian i
should know what discrimination feels
like
this is about
extreme gender ideology
the lesbians can have penises
male body sex offenders should be in
women's prisons we should lose our
sex-based rights
um
this is an ideological battle not a
generational one but many young women
and i hear from these young women all
the time
they're bullied out of
speaking about the feminism that they
understand to be feminism
so the abuse of prostitution the danger
of trans ideology
and they're told by the beards in their
lgbtqia two spirit plus groups
that usually lead those groups or their
feminist societies again the beards run
them
that they will be seen as swerfs and
turfs if they dare to
speak about male violence effectively
that's what they're shutting down that's
what they shut down when they stop me
going to universities they hate the
discussion about male violence the trans
thing is a kind of excuse it just gives
them a legitimate they think
platform from which to de-platform me do
you think your trans position is
mischaracterized totally
mischaracterized it's gender ideology
that i oppose and all of the feminists
that i know there are some anti-trans
women particularly in the states who
might call themselves feminist but
actually they're obsessed with this
issue for them it's a single issue
they've never done any campaigning
against male violence um they they're
just they're anti-trans they're anti um
lesbian and gay they're often
anti-abortion and they're not our
sisters right
they are not feminists
now the lunch with rowling and the other
women
we're friends
some of us have active friendships i've
known jo rowling for some time
we
actually talk about many things
connect in many ways as feminists
she's one of the funniest women that i
know
she's great fun great company and
a truly decent and good person
mischaracterized as evil
yadda yadda
some of the other women who were there
brave women alison bailey mayor force
data who've taken
cases in the public domain which means
that the emperor is stripped bare for
once they can't do like stone wall and
the trans activists can't do the whole
no debate
or empty chairs or refuse to turn up to
discuss this
they have been held to account by those
women raquel rosario sanchez she wasn't
at the lunch but she's someone that we
all know
who again took her university to court
um kathleen stock who was monstered out
of her job as a philosophy professor
we've formed friendships and alliances
and that's really important because
that's the history of the women's
liberation movement now a few very final
questions the first was just um
when it comes to the main political
parties uh you have a situation where
i think the tories more recently have
found uh their position on
of women's biology uh i think his
stamina is still looking for his and you
described the moment when boris johnson
declared that biological males should
not be allowed to compete in women's
sport as the week britain came to his
senses
and i wondered do you think um that if
this if this currently holds in terms of
what the main parties are saying so
um
some confusion on the labor side clear
position choice do you think you could
see some unlikely perhaps um
feminist figures backing the tories at
the next election do you think it's a
big enough issue to for people who i
don't you normally categorize as being
on the right if that makes sense
i hope not because i think we shouldn't
abandon the left the left is abandoned
us the male left the mainstream hard
left
um and and
i i will never vote tori
and i think feminism has to remain on
the left it doesn't have to be the hard
left
the hard left is very bad for women
i'm grateful when whoever's
in a position of power whoever's prime
minister or in government speaks out but
obviously boris johnson had a lot less
to lose than kyograma thinks he does
i don't think that makes boris johnson a
feminist he certainly isn't and i also
think
i wouldn't have chosen that headline
when britain came to its senses
it came to its senses because we have
been feminists have been banging on
about this issue for a long time
boris johnson spoke out which was great
um
but where the rest of them if you look
at the state of the other parties
they're just in total and utter disarray
over this issue because they don't
understand feminism and they don't
understand why we're challenging
transgender ideology
but i think we will prevail and things
are shifting in the right direction
definitely now final two questions um
you clearly obviously this is a life's
work um but i wondered in that time have
you have any of your views or opinions
changed over over the past you know few
decades oh definitely my opinions grow
and change um not necessarily
dramatically
because i think the underlying basis the
building bricks of feminism is
ultimately right you know we are a sex
class of women oppressed by a sex class
of men that doesn't mean all men oppress
all women it means that like for like
we're disadvantaged our views and
politics change with each um what's the
cliche bit of rich tapestry
it's the journey of the destination
oh god you haven't said journey once
thank god
yeah we need to get american accents or
reached out i've reached out on this
particular journey now the final
question we ask everyone on this podcast
is simply what is the worst advice
you've ever been given and you can of
course have completely ignored it
the worst advice i've ever been given
was thankfully advice i didn't take but
my god did it put me through the mill
worrying about it and thinking about it
and that was after i wrote
a piece in guardian weekend magazine in
2004
which was the first piece of mine that
i'd written about the transgender issue
that had gone online
so it was
carnage out there it was very critical
of a
trans a man who identified as a woman
who had tried to close down one of the
most important
women's organizations in canada called
vancouver rape relief
this person this trans woman had tied
them up in litigation because they
didn't want
um this trans woman to directly cancel
rape victims and it was the start of
hell of what turned into 20 years of
health this organization anyway i wrote
this column in the guardian
all hell broke loose
and the reader's editor wrote his column
on it
um
kath weiner who was
editor of weekend magazine at the time
now editor of the guardian she defended
and supported me she commissioned the
piece
and
i was
massively targeted it was the beginning
of
you know that for me
and i was advised by a senior journalist
keep your head down
don't speak of it apologize
say that you went too far
because there was some cheeky humor in
there
and just really stay away from this now
and i thought no no absolutely not
i can't do that i will apologize for my
tone
but i absolutely will not capitulate and
back down this is what feminists have
been told to do for decades don't upset
him don't be don't go too far
when bill clinton
was president and there were all the
allegations about sexual impropriety
including rape of a black woman against
him
there were some really really senior
feminists in the states telling the more
radical ones andrea dawkin who was a
friend of mine
don't kick off against bill clinton
because he's about to give us millions
of dollars for the end violence against
women program
which will revolutionize
the work that we're doing
and andrea said no
you do not capitulate you stand your
ground when it comes to issues like this
and i did stand my ground and had i
apologized and back down at the time
things would have been way worse for me
because they smell blood they come after
blood and this is a cruel sadistic
movement
and so they don't want your apology they
don't accept your apology they see it as
weakness
and you're in for way worse so thank god
i didn't take that advice
thank you
[Music]
you